that is welcome to your mom's house hi
mommy
hey little mommies I'm good mommy
just gotta figure it out that's like the
most boring video game ever let me know
if I'm turning you well welcome to your
mom's house
we did have a recorded version that we
we uh yeah put up a couple actually from
our living room somebody just turned
mine all the way down no I can hear it I
I know what boys like we did when they
did one lap we did a couch cast last
week that we sent you but apparently you
were dying
I'm Ryan yeah I uh I was in bed Rogan
got me sick and how do you say smoking
weed of course I'm the most dumbest
person ever I I always forget to not
smoke weed after somebody like like it's
so funny like if somebody music yeah
yeah somebody sneezes on you in your
face you're gonna be like what the fuck
and you're gonna freak out and run to
the bathroom right if you're smoking
weed you're gonna be like oh yeah that's
a little wet but I'm gonna put it in my
mouth you know and yeah that's sick more
than average because you fucking smoking
after Joey Diaz who's smoking out with
every single person in Mexico and then
like by the way we have to have him on
just to tell three shit stories that he
told me last week I don't want to get
into them but they're the most oh I know
one he says he said one before where he
didn't went out back yes isn't that the
ridiculous so he had me shaking shaking
in tears in cramped like about to have a
seizure yeah because I was laughing so
hard at that that's the most amazing
yeah you were in the room for that yeah
we got to have mom my girlfriend got
locked out of her house the other day
and she had just heard this story yeah
Joey Diaz and she was like sitting on
her patio waiting for me to get off get
home or whatever and and she's like
getting to the point where she couldn't
hold it anymore and she the only thing
she kept on thinking was Joey Diaz a
shit story makes is like should I do
that well you know what week it is guys
it's oh yeah
yeah it is it's Shark Week on Discovery
Channel but also in the mom's house it's
Shark Week it's Shark Week for a lot of
people throw well every week is Shark
Week at our house right yeah it's huge
we're trying to give people tips on
preparing for your sharts like
dark dark underwear carry a change of
clothes they need to make like period
underwear for guys or for people that
need to shit that's just black and red
with a little bit of white here and
there I have a fret I have a friend that
I was in I was in Montreal this past
week he showed him he went too far and
he Chardonnay no yeah you talked to on
the phone
Oh woodsy girls don't sharp that much
I have no come on I have never charted
and I say that with almost I have I've
had hot farts yeah like sweaty first
sweaty and kind of diarrhea worst yeah
I've caught mine I've gone to drop heat
and then like ooh that's gonna be a
little more than I wanted right there
yeah like I haven't really sharded in a
while but I'm hoping this week just just
to be like a you know I wanna I want to
have an honest char - but Tommy we've
been loading your barrels because we
kicked off short week yeah Sunday with
Korean barbecue yeah all day with some
beer and then the next day tacos at you
cos tacos yeah and then chili you know
you see the diet's working well doctor
points
I got we had the we had a brown what is
it about the wheat pasta with veggies
yeah we passed this key good stuff
garlic I want to get some garlic makes
me shit oh I've noticed the older I get
the more my asshole sweats yeah you know
what I mean specifically the whole like
like yeah it's like it's always a little
damp like I remember when I was a young
kid my ass is was just dry as a button
yeah nowadays it's like it's always just
got done running or being in the
audience of Ellen could it be like this
Santorum Santorum the tear ducts holy
asshole let's get into let's get into
this real quick
first of all Christina why don't you
introduce our one yes
guys I'm so happy to have this person
here today he is a Comedy Store regular
and one of my favorites please welcome
Justin Martin that's quad favorite
you're a you're a mommy today mommy yes
I'm very excited to tell you what
Santorum is you don't know what Santorum
is well barely not there is a I guess I
don't know if he's a senator or right
but I see a congressman or ass I don't
remember
well yeah anyways he's a very outspoken
conservative that's why I don't know him
yeah and I thought it was honestly
something that was like next to that
your taint like I honestly well it's
funny that you say that yes he is I
believe is he gonna run for president
god I hope so yeah look at him he looks
like a comedy like his song if he ran
for president would be eye of the tiger
yeah look at him fuckin four corners
kind of guy and yeah aren't they all now
like based on it's so dumb I'm so bored
dan Savage yes we've been talking about
who has a great podcast who we need to
plug as it doesn't have he's like
Professor X of the gay community I think
he's he's like a top-ten podcaster right
he's amazing if you listen to Dan Savage
you will learn about things you get is
mastered like like sounding which is
when people oh it's metal into their pee
now there's that but anything is really
great
oh wow he that's dark it got really was
like I'm thinking it gets better but
he's putting things in his pee hole but
he is is that really getting better
he has great insight though yeah and
horse heats rate he takes great calls
and I feel like he's basically the a
modern like our our sex expert doctor
who is like who is you know our our peer
like he's not
like 80 years old and like he's in our
age bracket and really has tremendous
knowledge and sort of like the what's
the the guy Kinsey Oh Kenzie Kinsey
Report right Sam but I feel like he's a
modern-day Kinsey who's even more you
know out stroke yeah yeah he really he
really gives you amazing insight but
anyways the story is that the Santorum
the reason they he did like a pole on a
show and and was talking about somebody
called in and like asked what's that
like the frothy mix of Lube and fecal
matter that is sometimes a result of
anal sex right and he was like well
there's not a name for that but we need
to come up with a name for that and his
listeners I think and they call and they
named it after him so saying I have
frothy ass sex right I was saying that's
probably what yeah that makes a lot of
sense because I never clean it out I
just keep the calm in my ass there you
go the naming it Santorum is that now
Rick Santorum in his like campaign ads
he stopped using his last name oh he's
like cher now so now he's just Rick he's
Rick and it's actually taken from the
Renaissance period or something where
people would shame you based on your
last name oh my god face looks like he's
just getting a little as Santorum down
his leg Santora Santorum Nina come up
with a Palin or Bachmann
come up with a Palin or a bomb he's
working on a Bachmann better be going
after Dan Savage I'm talking to you if
you need help
everybody's piled on Dan Savage early in
packing it's better he is he's really
gotten it bad do you think he's gay ahoo
Bachmann's oh my god it's so oh it hurts
did you see the guys who dressed up like
barbarians and went to his clinic no and
they were like we are barbarians we need
help
where is where's Marcus Bachmann and
like they were like we won Barca
and they threw glitter and started
dancing the edge of glory in the clinic
and this horrible woman with like a
floral dress down to her ankles it's
like it was brilliant I mean if I this
is one of those praying I'm gonna make
pray the gay away it's so fucking stupid
it's embarrassing it's I mean I grew up
very religious and it's just I mean it's
you can't well guess I tried and you can
let's give people a little bit of
backstory here oh yeah yeah where were
you from Texas
what part of Texas San Antonio Texas I
love my Spurs okay open some of it is
well Austin's a great time but often is
a great time San Antonio's of great town
Dallas is fine
one town
looks like that like the rec room for a
dream song is that it's the dick
detectives Oh detectives it's a new
games a new game we're playing okay
detective um
I mean okay so you've seen dicks I've
seen yeah you've seen dicks I've
definitely just watched a documentary on
your like Netflix that shit now busy
just just for me but I mean you know you
have problems hopefully let's say
hopefully you have more experience with
dicks than I do
yeah yeah like I know mine really well
I'm a wizard but I've seen so we've been
we've had this conversation yes this is
an ongoing debate in our marriage I
don't know how positive it is but it's
about dicks and basically it's the idea
of whether or not you can guess a dick
size based on any other physical feature
totally can totally can I'm of that
school of thought as well that and tall
lanky fellow will have a tall lanky wing
yeah a short stout fellow we'll have a
little tuna can P be getting warmer what
do you think well this is what I think I
mean I agree
really I think I mean there's definitely
here there's definitely mutant wild card
I'm sure like you know because I'm sure
there's some mutant south the the idea
the thought yeah that that's not
accurate
well there you go that was a woman my
thoughts are based on oh okay it's based
on having watched an exceptional amount
of pornography I've also you know I've
been on I played team sports I've been
around the cock block a few times I've
stood in in locker rooms and I think
from my experience tells me that you can
that sometimes it's true and you can
presume that but a big tall guy can have
a little Wang
short a fucking five-foot-five guy can
have a hog on them yeah they're they're
mutants yeah sure
so there's definitely I mean there's
gonna be like the impressive ones like
won't you know right right
she's nice small skinny ones tool just
like you're like God Almighty you know
right a little skinny little has a real
yeah black snake on a black that's all
thank you yeah it's I have a very very
very I like I'm very proud of it really
yeah it's you huge hog yeah really
that's the dick detective work that this
is how Tom and Christina interview their
new people I mean I'm very comfortable
with that had a really good really
really good run and do you get like I
never I've never in my put me off
herself how am I in my dating days I
never got to like whoa you're good get
out of here with that thing so you have
that though yeah really liked okay you
put I don't Lea had some like really
yeah you've had you've been turned down
it's a little different going pussies
like stretch okay tell that to your girl
that's your girlfriend yeah can we have
to be so crude sorry ladies he's down
and I've even turned down a just just
too much too much me yeah it's not oh
yeah I remember that story it's not that
great much for you it's like it's not
enjoy right that's got to be a really
that's got actually I've sounds cool but
like if you're the guy but the guy so
the guy you're like hooking up and like
you're kissing and then he's like how
about Disney you're like oh no sorry I
gotta go
seriously yeah I you're here you feel
kind of like a badass yeah I don't get
your let's at least kiss it and we'll
put on your cheeks and snow
emotion but I don't why do I care about
have you ever though like sought out a
guy gone back and I'm like oh oh yeah
yeah yeah so sometimes your what your
your you know your guests can be wrong
it can be off yeah I mean can't yours
yeah well sure but I'm saying like
you're specifically with us for you Dan
Savage like Shaq Shaq was a famous
Shaquille O'Neal right yeah I'm sure
it's like it's like yeah what it's
famous for not being huge yeah that's
probably what he just says just because
it Enrique Iglesias apparently got on
stage and it was Melbourne Australia got
on stage I don't know did his bailamos
thing I don't know what you know I liked
it was 99 is a good year but he got on
stage apparently it was like I have a
small penis no really seriously its
small just talked about talked about it
if anyone wants it just talk but I'm
like he has a song called I'm fucking
you tonight I'm like not with that thing
you're not I once dated an average-sized
boy like he was like average build
average everything in his weenus was so
small that it was it was really bad it's
like a sad thumb it was I would say
these two fingers together my pinky and
then my ring finger together and that's
about the Lobos hard hard no did you day
for a long time oh we were friends and
then we like hooked up and then it was
just like that's really do women have
that vagina I mean are their vaginas
dilators girls that have huge floppy
meaty vaginas and there's girls that
have like little tight little like cute
i buy vaginas and then and then there's
I mean
it's one's different in your swing set
yeah yeah and there was a girl I've said
this before I think there's this girl
that I used that when I would suck her
pussy it would you would stretch out
like like it would stretch on the size
of a dick of how long it was like I felt
like I was giving head to a guy but see
what yeah okay I was like Beethoven's
fifth yes
now what is that correlated to like are
you doing Justin on an average-sized
male let's say guys six feet 190 he
meets like the average stats you just do
you just anticipate an average slung on
them is that what I want I want to get
to know him first
well who cares about it I'm talking
about just just dicks in general is that
the size you're expecting though is it
average-sized right I would say uh to be
good yeah yeah and a fight like a how
about a short guy like you just expected
is he Latin oh that's different
you know they're you know that Puerto
Ricans are her fuckin I love Puerto
Ricans yeah and they can have huge dongs
no but Puerto Ricans the ones like all
the Puerto Ricans travel American dicks
I'm crushed do you think among that race
that's a thing I think in my experience
the Puerto Ricans for some reason
they're they're shorter but they're hogs
are just Russian Jews tend to have yeah
what do you think Martin how many
different races have you been whole gap
commercial cast of Glee so you know I
don't like like white white white that's
not my flavor
so the Ricans that you've been with have
healthy hogs yeah Russian Jews Russian
Jews you've had Russian Jews yeah I like
Jews really they're good in bed usually
they're usually more fun right yeah but
there do have mommy issues that's the
problem so much fucking hang-ups with
mommy
so I'm not into that
all right I never had a black eye though
well you you you've told me as in secret
that you have but you just have to say
that round Tommy hey wait I was talking
to Justin what were you guys talking
about well we didn't really detect one
we don't know that you don't know who
can we speculate on but we need
confirmation don't wait for the game to
to work or no no just the detectives
about it I tried to solve
are you not interviewing me look I
already showed his dick why all right
how about The Hobbit Elijah I don't know
if Elijah Wood is a Russian Jew I'm
predicting that he's got quite a hog on
him really yeah policy he's short played
a hobbit no I would say no very short
that's magical I think he has a very you
know just average size yeah you know I
think he's better than average okay so
two for average one for a healthy hog
something Russian yeah I think it'd be a
little small but maybe a little fat
Elijah if you're out there tweet us at
ah you've got you've got fans I've got
four of them right here who are all
talking about your dick we're going just
from one update to in this well I was
actually concerned about your last
general update I didn't hear the the
mommy
the last mommy that you guys did a long
did you have a dental update during this
no no I did because I was having some
sensitivity in the upper left area and I
thought that maybe it might be cavity
but it was just a Liza's penis
no and so far so good but we did get a
dental update from your mom's house
alumni Oh Matt full shrine Matt photo
one of my favorite episodes now and I
did so full charge he got a discount I
think from Kaiser $15 discount for
mentioning the mom's house that's great
that's great yeah there's the coupon
code your mom's house yes most dentists
are a hundred percent on board yeah go
to a dentist mention your mom's house
see what happens so Justin you may not
know this but we have dental update yeah
we'd start on the show because we had
like a horrible dentist week and so we
do this every second every show do you
have a dental update how are your teeth
my teeth are fine you have nice do you
have nice teeth man yeah thank you are
they are real I need to actually go to
the dentist soon it's you gotta go but I
brushed my teeth twice a day you've lost
it's not like I was like yeah not as
much what what you got what are you my
like get out me brush my teeth this
weekend go home it was great having me
guys thank you take some oral be on your
way out I do have a dental update see I
don't know if I've ever said this before
when I was a kid and knocked my two
front teeth out and that they're the
only thing left are like two little
fangs of a million teeth yet so they put
on these two temporary teeth on top of
my little Fang teeth yeah and I've had
him ever since I was a kid and and one
of the teeth like the dentists at the
time was like alright these are
temporary they're good for a while but
you need to get these replaced with like
legit teeth but my mom was too broke so
we never did it so I just kept him as
long as I can and then one time I was
working in this call center job and I
was eating at the lunch in my lunch
break and I like bit open a sweet and
sour packet in it one of my teeth just
flew out schools and so it was four tick
I think much Ticket Master if I go back
out I'm like oh my god I can't I can't
we'll go back to work my teeth just fell
out and he goes we need you man we need
you I'm like seriously I said that then
I had to be like thank you for calling
Ticketmaster blue milk makes the best
with the preferred method the payment
this call may be monitored for quality
sense purposes by a supervisor this is
Bryan speaking how can I help you you
know like the whole spiel you remembered
that I'm a drone now it gets fried in
your head so the guy finally my boss was
like all right yeah you can't be talking
like this you know whatever go home so I
got that tooth replaced with a better
tooth but my other tooth is still the
one from when I was 12 that they're like
this is temporary you know so so had it
that long yeah it's awful is it brown
it's horrible wouldn't wait yeah I need
I need two veneers in my friend but I
also need to win the lottery to do that
but yeah so expensive so last night I
was drinking wine out of a bottle which
is what you do I think I chipped a
little teeny piece off it now so now I'm
starting to get really concerned about
how much are like just the single
replacements expensive I think for two
veneers I I want to say it's almost
$1,000 a tooth or more luck
it might be more than that really
because I asked I do my two front teeth
also cuz I knocked one of them out as a
kid right so every like 10 years I have
to replace my two friends but if you do
porcelain right it's about eight hundred
or thousand bucks each
yeah but you veneer Meniere's like two
or three grand I think yeah see I almost
want to just do it right the first time
thing you know they're already kind of
shaved out I don't like the way veneers
look I don't really like the way they
look like Donkey Kong
can I just say that song is bullshit cuz
I've passed every Christmas show me your
teeth no I bet I want for Christmas is
my two front teeth yes I've been asking
for it's bullshit so kids just fuck that
song up yes no no those were really poor
those were really poor parents too right
that's all that kid warning
soon just let them grow
my uncle knocked him out mommy likes
math my um I've been flossing a lot more
and not really bleeding anymore
oh yeah after a while I'm real proud of
myself now to use the sticks or do you
use the the old school stick slice the
dick Oh or do you use like that no that
I use well cuz sometimes you know you
see people like some people will put
like toilet paper on the end of a stick
to wipe herself
greenies people who can't get out of bed
lazy sacks of shit yeah do that that
South Park Rick Cartman was like a crane
crane II yeah crane either they have to
go weigh him down at the pier I've never
heard that term before I just soak a
towel and put it on the bathroom floor
wipe my butt on it like a dog like
Gilbert grapes mom she does a crane I
get I use I use old school floss but she
fucking yells at me for how much I use
what does it matter to you like you're
not don't waste that shit did the grown
tree I've asked you to wipe me so you
can find out I want you to see how much
toilet paper is necessary is a great
idea
ya know because he was it and waz it and
wads and I'm like how do you know you
haven't seen me do I'm telling you when
you're not home I use one roll of toilet
paper it lasts me about two weeks when
you're home we go through one fucking
roll in three days yeah I'm telling
white me bite me tomorrow yeah just like
write it down like first toilet paper
did about 20% listen yeah tomorrow
morning when I take the morning heater
you're coming in and you're wiping me I
accept your child can you play take my
breath away in the background
I crushed it do you wipe standing up or
sitting down I gave away my husband
remember last time this one's for me
yeah we talked about that on this we did
we did okay my husband comes home off
the road and he he make sweet love to me
and he turns to me and he goes this
one's for me
roll over that was just like I was like
seriously like five pumps I was like
what I told her ahead of time like this
is mine this is just for me it's not for
you five magical pumps yeah so so this
time I came home and what happened I'd
say you schooled me yeah you tore that
shit I gave her a lesson
he was like Rocky he trained for it I
don't know what he did and I was so
surprised
I really no I was speechless yeah that's
good I talked about how I recently got
told that I too loud by my neighbor what
my little Korean neighbor who I thought
died now how did how does one tell you
you fuck to it I was walking down doing
laundry and I'm walking by her and she's
talking to this woman and she just goes
oh he did one who had eight not six no
exactly and I stopped turned and was
like how dare you but at the same time I
mean I'm like right on right no but I
mean this is absolutely not so you were
making a guy fucking scream basically
yeah you do have a fucking it's awesome
yeah a good month yeah so are you are
you dating somebody or just you're kind
of playing the field or what now let's
okay let's get into this we were talking
kind of about this earlier I mean you're
a gracious enough to join us you gave us
green light to ask all kinds of
questions you are our gay expert cool
one of the things that we were talking
about was that people
always most the time I should say assume
the gay guys are all extremely
promiscuous and but you were saying that
you're not like that where's that mean
it's it's it's definitely a phase like
when you're when you're young or you're
just like you've got this yeah yeah but
then once you turn like 25 and gave it
your fuzzy 25 and dead should be a new
show 20 now we were discussing this
earlier that I'm not sure what's worse
is la woman years oh yeah or gay man
years like that's so age young master
obviously guys I mean
well women I don't know the housewives
though I mean they're they're on fire I
feel like la you like u-turn that's true
they are on fire Beverly I love Lisa
Vanderpump because Cougars are because I
would but generally speaking in LA
you're like 27 or some people are like
people are like like you're 26
you're a old chick like they're really
horrible in LA yeah well I mean here's
interesting there's that there's that
guy that actor 50 year old actor guy who
married that 16 year old but how old
does she look 25
really yes 26 la 25 no I mean she I mean
obviously when I saw her I'm like oh
she's like 25 no I swear I thought she
was like 33 or something everybody in
America did - yeah yes I mean it's like
that was being Janis she's like I'm a
Christian and she's like I'm just like
wait it's one of those like sad girls
were like yeah when I found Jesus I'm
like he put you in a canoe and like made
a music video like really does look
older really it's just weird I'm just
like yeah it's like that whole it's the
guy from LA he used to work yeah who was
he and lost yeah I don't I don't
remember him exactly so if we can find
out his vegetable loss because I was a
fan of plus and I don't remember and
there was a lot of cast members in that
show I was watching that show that has
like the little kids in the fashion
what's that Suge Hutchinson's his name
and you know that would be the best job
if you were a child molester to be a
judge on that show because I mean that
one guy was just like oh
I was like watching the judges like she
was just gorgeous
oh no no like one eyes like dead like it
was the most complicated coffee stain on
his shirt the guy who sings I'd love
that is it he's like let all math
perfect dreams afraid find it please
because it's the weirdest and he's like
and sunshine and rainbows and the end
the parents are in the audience like
it's so gross anybody to be like
gorgeous to a six yeah but then the
little girls be like I know and you're
like you it's not good but then they get
on 16 and pregnant and then they get on
t months that covers of Us Weekly I know
that's a special military toddlers and
tiaras I don't I don't know what that
song is anyways anyway so okay so one of
the things we were talking about you may
have already schooled other people in
this on another project was we became
fascinated with the subculture yeah
within the gay umbrella I love oh god I
hope I'm doing the gays just I'm just
like oh god guys my back tweet something
you know we lived yes but I know
yes and so we passed by there a lot and
like I lived in San Francisco for five
years and so I thought I had a pretty
good grasp on it but even now they're
like evolving and changing so I know
that there's bears yeah which is hairy
older I just I just realized this
morning by the way till you told me I
didn't realize that bear was
age-specific neither did I didn't
realize that so yeah I thought okay
there's our Bears and the Cubs I just
thought a Cubs or younger bears careless
no that's no twinks yeah give us a
lesson there's a whole animal subculture
right like we were talking about dr. oh
who are we talking about
no Dan Savage they were talking
I was like he's like he's like a silver
little silver silver little otter silver
honor right what's an otter tell the
otters like it like a slender guy with
hair on his chest but you put white on
top of his head a little gray yeah it's
like a little silver on silver otter you
be a regular artery regular AAR's just
like a taller person with chest hair so
are you an otter I know I'm no animal
and the anime how come you're not an I
dare no I was a twink and then I just
I'm like I'm like Peter Pan I don't know
I I'm not a tweet the old but you were
to I was a twink what's there was a time
explain specifically what a tweens
that's getting younger are like a skinny
young hairless boyish okay kid you're a
vampire so they're considered a vamp in
my opinion no that's what I would say
I've actually had someone call me an eel
I thought that was really gross he's a
vampire it's oh I got like a slim like a
hairless tall heels between your legs
and everything called a trunk which is I
think I'm a crystal a crystal seahorse I
think that's I'm sure he has a soul
there's somebody that wants to fucking
just smash them oh yeah I think that's
that's a bear cub that's a hybrid yeah
why actually he has a vagina you just
can't see it
no good no they do yeah they don't have
animals and the lesbian ones really fast
I didn't really like one of those shows
like I'm so real I don't see it but I
know like I know like I'm blown away
when I see I kind of wanna have a lot of
lesbian friends that I'm like I need to
get on board it's like a quiet
underground thing no one really talks
about the real well at least the ones
that I've spoken to in our neighborhood
they're like that's bullshit but
straight women love it
I watch it cuz I watched the l-word cuz
it's like just hot chicks like drama
it's like
- I know with lesbians okay yeah and the
real word they're not as attractive all
of them nope there's one girl with like
a head full of smelly dreads ooh that's
great dreads on anybody
all right listen Jen der groe the shift
shells on them - dude yeah it's awesome
Dom Cancun spring break 96 are you blown
away when you meet like genuinely
good-looking lesbians I am I'm always
lipstick lesbians yeah yeah but I think
I'd never have met one that was a
hundred percent like I've never I have
really a lipstick lives yes I have the
most the most gorgeous girl so she's
dating the they were actually both very
very gorgeous that's mine my name's
Allison and she is like this gorgeous
lesbian it's like gorgeous girlfriend
and the two of them together just hot
never seen I'm fascinated I've never
seen it here that's the thing I mean
Allison's obviously the little like oh
she's a little butcher of the - yeah
she'll put I mean she'll put a tie on
have like a button-down but I mean she's
still gorgeous so it's just kind of like
whatever and then you know her
girlfriend comes in it's just like hey
what like it really so pretty it is and
I get it it's just yeah need more of
those and just get rid of it and trans
there's all kinds of transition
everyone's weird kids are just gay at
10/9 yard and hey asshole have you made
a fucking video to tell them that it
gets better or not okay I will make a
video we're trying to make Justin feel
he'll make I do feel horrible I've never
made a game gets better video now this
is every like everyone's on board
I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna it's gonna be
amazing are you supposed to do it though
I'll do it with you guys know what it is
explain them there's so many campaigns
for equality and stuff and I'm all about
it you know it's cool I like I like the
Human Rights Campaign right Trevor
Project all these like is I mean there's
so much like right so it's a really cool
movement that I'm very excited to be a
part of especially like doing this as a
profession cuz right thanks and so and I
have to tell people that it's actually
pretty awesome but explain to him like
oh well there's like the no hate
campaign right like it started out like
I guess I want to say like maybe two
three years ago right
Adam busca as a photographer he started
no hate you
yeah and you know it was the like duct
tape with Rio and it started getting a
little more celebrity we're like you
know the Kardashians for know hey and
it's like oh like Cindy McCain Cindy
McCain McCain's daughter did it you know
a lot of people have done it so yeah but
I never did it like there was all these
like photo shoots and I will never turn
down a photo shoot but I'm like oh you
know it was something that I kind of
didn't I mean I'm all for it but III I
just hate the image of duct tape over my
now my job is to like speak and like you
know I don't know and and I just never
did it and I'm gonna do that and then it
gets better it should be like you know
all those kids were killing themselves
and it was like I mean it was a huge who
started this was this killing it was
committing suicide town yeah they were
coming out and their parents were
kicking them out it's awful timing them
and yeah and it still goes on and it's
just it's it's sad I mean these kids get
tormented in school and the fact that I
mean to be I mean I remember when I was
14 I was watching like Power Rangers I
wasn't thinking about hanging myself
because you know I mean I got teased a
lot in school but it's something that
luckily I had the ability to take a hold
of and like use my comedy use my
popularity in school to kind of like
yeah do it I mean it works out thank God
you know but I mean I couldn't imagine
being in like ballsack Wyoming it's sad
so then then I'm sorry to the people Bob
sack if I used your town in a negative
way the idea though came about was all
this was going on and then savage
created a video yeah where he said where
he's telling the the movements or the
campaign is called it gets better yet
you're essentially telling telling kill
your kids out of their high schools not
that being being like you know being
open being who you are and you're a
person you're a human being for God's
sakes I mean so a lot of like comics
Ellen did one like Adam Lambert did one
Neil Patrick Harris Obama yeah I mean
now a whole bunch of like sports teams
are doing it like it's still going it's
a boy house they're did one yeah yeah I
mean I mean I never did what I felt
warble I mean I was I was
like you know what cuz I alright so you
said it before red band in the other
previous podcast you're making a promise
today the whole story huh you're making
a promise today to make animation it
gets better I will be friends with Dan
Savage by the end of this budget we all
want to meet the establishment yes it's
happening
he's awesome you think we can get them
in here and fly them down listen dan
savage we love you and if you're ever in
LA come to your mom's house your mom's
here come see her
so should we yeah so yeah yeah we have a
special thing planned today because we
knew Justin was coming in and and we
could ask questions yeah and have an
open dialogue about I'm the new dr. Drew
again listen I'm the token female on so
many things and now my good friend our
good friend we marriage I just me it's
only about and anything that I say his
life Christina can come along too yeah
come on let's go divert the great
comedian Brent Weinbach who is a just a
hilarious person we did a sketch that we
shot called bear in a bathtub and I
pitched I pitched him the idea and he
loved it and then he was like well you
should get you know what he can do for
music and I was like I know I'm thinking
about his stuff he was like do you know
his eyes lit up when I pitched him to
skip the sketch idea was basically that
I'm a bear in a bathtub okay I got it
and that a woman calls and goes and
calls like an animal trainer and goes
there's a bear in my tub that's awesome
and then it turns out it's a it's a it's
a gay bear that's awesome and then he
but he drank he tames it the way it's
like it tastes like a grizzly bear like
a grizzly bear but it's a gay bear right
did you stand up right my roar and
everything yeah
we had a lot of fun making it and you
can see it it's on I think it's on Funny
or Die
it's called bear in a bath parent
yeah so why we're doing this when I
pitched at Brent's eyes like lit up his
eye I still want to be a part of this
yeah I was like all right so we started
talking about music he goes have you
heard of this band this group hirsute
pursuit and I was like no he goes you
need to check them out we didn't end up
using their music for the sketch but we
still research her super suit and it is
the most intensely aggressive game music
oh good I can't wait I'm gonna run out
myself on fire preface this by saying
that hirsute pursuit they don't have a
website they're still on MySpace
yeah yeah so when I when we googled them
it became an obsession that we had to oh
you got that on now
here tell me that would you oh my god no
yeah never open the thing for me babe
hold on
first of all it's titled oh no I don't
need it they're mine I got it so anyways
I had twenty dollars in my bank account
at the time Tom and I were living in
downtown LA broke and I spent 16 of
those 20 dollars with getting this
hairsuit pursuit CD and it came to us
and the cover the graphic design on the
cover is it's written income yes semen
no it's not that's supposed to be semen
I see men and it says HP for her super
suit unless I can cock thoughts oh my
god
it's called cock we queued the fog
Oh gross there's there's grunting that's
what I wanted a real reaction it's very
intense
it's very intense I I wish I had a
whistle around my neck
now does this make you go that's too
much it sounds like Halloween music yeah
it sounds like if I was gonna corn maze
that's what I'd want to the next track
it's hard what do you think of this of
this track here
okay just let it play wait for it go for
it
this is about to get dangerous that's
not that's why of the human eight I'm
gonna fuck that hole until you can't
fucking see straight Oh
oh okay you like there's no tomorrow
oh really
fuck you raw how'd you know I was new in
town
I think there's a rape Appetit okay it's
like this is dungeon rape style you
definitely couldn't have a cocktail
party business yeah definitely it's not
fab yeah it's really aggressive it's
terrifying
it's terrified thank you that's exactly
I mean if I like if you guys were in
your house doing dishes and I was your
neighbor who play are you disgusted I
would be the neighbor to be like set
there dog no it's something else
the renters association would send you a
letter like they would be like okay they
have I mean this is if I could classify
this this would be dungeon music yeah
this is this is the pits of hell hog
masks yeah there's a movie the guy that
didn't avoid yeah I saw that yeah maybe
he did before that hear like there's I
couldn't get through the whole thing I
was like okay I'm done yeah it kind of
sounds like down the hall someone's
being tortured yeah it's you know this
is haunted house music this is I mean
play this play this for Halloween this
year
could you play the neck with children
coming to your door no way yeah it's
called not hibernating this is a bear I
know yeah go all the way start it over
again it was a good thing Lube is a good
this is a tic catch a predator episodes
oh my god well yeah
come here that was like Santa yeah yeah
nipples are like erasers actually uh
while we're listening to this yeah you
should pull that orange flashlight out
and just open it up and give it to
Justin okay oh really oh oh yeah what do
you want me to do with that I have
friends who have these I know again it's
clean right yeah don't go okay Jesus
like put your hand in there am i RI oh
but it would be appropriate with this
song well now what is that a mouth or a
vagina
that's a vagina okay I mean I know I
know what a vagina looks like it's kind
of Malfi yeah I don't have a nose or
eyes
oh right that's gross Q Ari Shaffir
everyone Ari Shaffir come on in come on
in asshole someone came back Canada he's
like did someone say flesh Jack and like
open the door somewhere around here we
want you to hear something
ari you need to hear this so this song
is called not hydrating hibernating hi
Bernard red van haver what is it
Piper I'm waiting don't play words with
friends with him it's really hard to
hear what this folks even going on to me
it just sounds like a drum beat totally
into it
wait how many more are on that okay it's
like yes that is so aggressive no
hesitation
you get when I snap my fingers I want
you to sit down on this big fucking tent
pole and I want you to sit down all the
way okay I did it's actually a pilot I'm
working on it's gonna be on II get that
thing lined up with that butthole and
you sit straight down all the way these
are your lines are eight actually this
is your character that we yeah it's very
instructive yeah it's very like no it's
very straightforward - no no we were
calling this if you were to classify
this music it would be called dungeon
dungeon trance or what was it dungeon
yeah look there's semen on the cover
that spells H and P yeah I'm kind of
grossed out
well I got something better than this
what this is something called gangster
fag I don't know if you've ever heard
this before or not this is something
that Rogen actually Dan Savage it gets
better
Mike's not working for some reason
we're very Pro pro Baron probe area this
is called gangster Fagin somebody thanks
turfy yeah he contacted Joe Rogan a long
time ago and gave him a CD and and Joe
always keeps everything everything is
just like never looks at it like his
like boxes of CDs and then one time he
looked at it and he listened to it and
he showed it to me and it's one of the
most funniest fall re-baited
did he really faint yeah oh he's a
regular meat loaf but uh so anyways this
song if you listen to the lyrics of it
it is some of the most fucked up shit
where he's fucking this dude in his
kid's room and he wipes his come on like
the teddy bear the kid but it's it's one
of the best CDs ever it sounds like
that's amazing that was a great pitch
leading up to this is one of the best
things can it go into my iphone along
with the Carpenters that would be
awesome
of course I just like their cover if I
know how boys like it's not bad I know
what boys like I know what boys he was a
big part of this of this album
yeah he's his voice is actually on this
so we did some research of a Mack SF and
it is this is a very distinct subculture
oh yeah there's a whole I mean there's
there's there's it's like the solar
system there are planets that you have
not even seen yeah were you ever into
these types of like pseudo it was
terrified of them yeah not like it's not
like I'm like yo they're horrible people
no I never got into that like you know
suit by day and
definition my night you know it was like
holy a subculture here's that gangster
fag always do you think they can turn
out your boyfriend oh I have some I have
some really hot straight friends I
really no no no no I like them as
friends I don't want to ruin and make it
awkward I mean I've done that you have
done that I like about everything that's
like I regretted it because I don't talk
to those people anymore yeah I mean it's
nothing recently it was like yeah last
night you know but they always say yes
cuz at the end of the day a guy wants a
blowjob right is that what happens no no
I got some good I mean I mean right
Tommy I have some straight friends that
are like cool with their sexuality now
and they'll just like fuck with you like
it's just great they'll be like yeah oh
really
oh yeah and then their girlfriends like
cool with it - she said shut up and I'm
just like thank you right babe oh you're
the best this is actual soap you brought
soap oh you have a tub of water there I
know I got butt wipes so good is there
anything yeah but I know I mean I think
I mean we're talking as dirty as we are
I mean I think it's appropriate we bring
out wipes at some point yeah don't wipe
his ass right by the way unfortunately
the the people at home can't smell this
whole office now smells like it's really
hot in LA
I'll have the air conditioning off so
it's like humid in here and it smells
like ass it's like so much that Ari
fainted it's is he still on the ground
yeah he's still laying on is like Bikram
mom cast yeah it's yeah it's hot it's
hot you know it is hot and plus we're
listening to all this and that was a
that shit's intense right well this one
I like it's catchy
listen to the listen to what happened oh
there's more oh yeah that was just tick
off on his kids anyways there's like
five songs you can get him on YouTube
it's actually do no I don't think he
actually appeared I think it was one of
those guys that give out CDs like hey
listen my CD
he was like I'm gangster yeah that's
where it happened Rogen was odd in a gay
he went to a gay parade you know how
sunset always closes down they had that
gay parade one Santa Monica I say
tomorrow yeah yeah he went one year and
some guy gave it to him there and he was
like oh okay
was it boom Shakalaka a bit
well good you know I've always thought
there needs to be a shanwa of gay rap I
don't know why there isn't there was one
chick who did it I don't know if she's
still doing it and she's a lesbian yeah
yeah that's that white girl right yeah
that's that white girl right oh shit
she's like going into that Hollywood
Highland shop all like yeah she's like
she's the girl living in right oh she's
like she's like Taylor Swift mm oh shit
yo cop that creation kid cop that shit
up wait so Justin we didn't get to this
earlier but so our audience knows how
did you get started because you started
a few years ago right how did you get
started in stand-up oh I got I mean I
was I just did it you just did it like
for you that's an honest there's
something you had been wanting to do for
a while uh no I was curious about it and
I saw some guy on TV and I was like I
mean my whole life people were like you
should totally do stand-up and it was
just like oh no and then I was just kind
of like an appoint my phone oh fucking
dudes do it whatever what I got to lose
and I did it was like it was like that a
lot of you know it kind of spoke to me
where I was like okay I think it's time
that somebody like me kind of yeah spoke
up yeah yes I like I mean that and I
like that where it's like I could talk
to people who are like dude you're
you're really really good and you're
kind of cool like hanging out with you
I'm like well thank you I'm a I'm a he
thanks for not having sex with me oh
thank you for not embarrassing me in
front of my girlfriend
but I'm also like a good like I'm also a
good a comics girlfriend person to have
like if usually if you want to leave
your girlfriend yeah sure like hey Marty
element oh just interesting I wonder if
gay men have the same thing that women
do when we get on stage where people are
kind of like I don't know what to do
with you totally really fight yeah does
that lead you to then go I like to want
to develop less material about being gay
so I don't talk about it really yeah so
that people don't go oh of course you're
fucking I mean if I talk about it it
comes out like organically all right so
I've seen that where I'm just like why
would you do that to yourself yeah well
that's how I feel about women who are
like my boyfriend I don't talk about
your fucking pussy or like an Asian so
I'm Korean oh you get it yeah
but it's like I mean it's a it's a it's
that thing I mean I feel like I'd rather
have somebody like me for who I am and
what I have to say rather than like who
I'm having sex with right though you
know I'm not a big creepy pervert out
there like well no one's just changing
now to I think it back in the 80s people
had to be like I'm gay and here's the
act like rip rip taylor shit
no glitter in the air and women had to
be less a single lady you know and it's
evolved everything's kind of evolving oh
yeah becoming people as opposed to our
gender and it's so weird actually did
this show as you say that that I did
this show at the left or no at the
improv my factory I'm working on it
but it was like a kid like at a camp I
was like all these kids it was like
Marquette Marc Ellis was in there with
me and we walked in there it felt like a
Showbiz Pizza like it was terrifying I
was so scared
what the hell do I have in common with
these kids but it was great because I
got on stage it was just like I gotta
talk I gotta talk to what they're
talking about and stuff and this kid
this one kid was just like all right
bitch and I was like how dare you I was
like you're obviously gay you have these
like girls around you and he was like
good-looking wearing a tank top fucker
right yeah and and like he was just like
okay and like afterwards like he came up
with sure he's like good stuff buddy I
was like oh it is it made me go and I
had this like you know okay I like
speaking up for kids like they had a
hard and I just did a teen tour show at
The Improv yeah and there was like a
quick girl in the audience and I was
goth and I was talking about being a
totally we're gonna cut her yeah yeah no
I didn't see her yeah yeah it's just
it's funny now but at the time but I
could see her little face and I was oh
that's so cool like if she just knows
that one person grew up and grew up okay
and normal and I'm not fucked up anymore
you know and and you can do drugs when
you're 15 okay yeah it's just so weird
that we still live in a world where
people can say what's right and what's
wrong and I just love it when it comes
back and just smacks them right in the
face yeah like God just like who are you
you know Anthony Weiner oh boy like why
can't like the Bachmann's the others so
disgusting braylon's the way and the
fact that we're glorifying that we're
gonna have Bristol on Dancing with the
Stars she's going around telling people
like uh you know I'm an advocate for
abstinence
Shirley I okay I'm completely gonna
listen to everything you say Plastics oh
it's just gross
it's gross and I want to like I'm gonna
tell kids I mean it's like you have I
mean you have that that those people in
gay society and straight society who
they see whatever the shit is on
Newsweek or Us Weekly or whatever
they're like okay this is what I have to
be into right now you know and it's just
like God just you you were allowed to
turn off the garbage I know that's why
you have to show them that you're a
person and not just a dick sure I mean
you - I get it though I'm not I don't
watch it but I get it I get it
those guys are smart entertaining it's
so I mean I mean we live in a culture
where it's like it is crazy how much
money they have made those kids really
make money music it used to be your show
your hit show would be you know a lot
there be fuckin 20 staff writers and you
know gang of producers and this
incredibly massive crew working to get a
show that you hope becomes a hit and
comes hit you like well this is
literally throw fucking 40 cameras in a
house and you put these Guido's in the
fucking house and then they're like this
is a hit show like you just being a
fucking douche bag in a tank top that's
a that's a hit you're gonna make five
million dollars a year or more whatever
just being like hey fucking guy there's
our paycheck sir no meatballs wait let
me get this straight
I get the fuck girls and hang out in hot
tubs and make a bunch of money
that's right situation it's called
Hollywood yeah I could buy so much
pomade yeah welcome back any time
bye mommy hi mommy hi mommy